[Musica]
[Applauso]
qual è il primo pensiero che viene in
mente quando lo speaker ha davanti a voi
per 10 secondi
sta zitto questo sei dimenticato il
discorso in realtà stavo pensando al
sapete che cosa succederà nel 2043 la
fine del mondo il dominio delle
intelligenze artificiali su quelle umane
può essere però c'è solo una cosa che è
certa è che accadrà nel 2043 nel 2043
finisce il mio mutuo e oggi sono qui a
parlarvi del mio mutuo è un mutuo 25
anni tasso fisso 1,7 per cento
non male no ovviamente ovviamente no
oggi sono qui però a raccontarvi come la
scadenza del mio mutuo mi abbia portato
per la prima volta in maniera concreta a
pensare a che cosa succederà nel 2043 ci
avete mai pensato
ci avete mai pensato quello che è certo
è che ogni giorno che passa ci sono
sempre più sfide che noi dobbiamo
accogliere per beneficiare
dell'innovazione tecnologica e per non
esserne vittima perché di vittime ce ne
sono state e ce ne sono state anche di
illustri storia di blockbuster è
incredibile chi tra noi almeno una volta
non hanno leggiate un dvd vhs
vhs da blockbuster qualche mano
fantastico oggi non c'è più
l'origine del fallimento di blockbuster
quale non sono riusciti ad anticipare la
potenza di internet non hanno capito
come internet avrebbe impattato il loro
modello di business nella produzione e
nella distribuzione di contenuti video e
di conseguenza non si sono adattati al
digitale
tanto da rifiutare un acquisizione da
parte di netflix nel 2000 e oggi netflix
vale oltre 100 miliardi di dollari
però torniamo un attimo al al 2043
proviamo a pensare a che cosa succederà
nel 2040 tra prendiamo un bel respiro e
aiuta anche a me in questo discorso che
cosa succederà nel 2043 per farlo
proviamo a seguire questo percorso il
primo iniziamo a invertire i paradigmi
dei nostri schemi mentali
come seconda cosa inizialmente l'odore
un po di pazzia nel nostro modo di
ragionare un po come il bianconiglio in
in alice nel paese delle meraviglie
uno dei miei personaggi preferiti e come
terza cosa
iniziamo a sentire ad ascoltare quella
voce che secondo me tutti noi in maniera
latente abbiamo dentro e che ci chiede
di interrogarci ogni giorno conti
quotidianamente sull'urgenza
dell'informazione relativa
all'innovazione tecnologica che sta
impattando il nostro mondo e la nostra
società bene ora che abbiamo questi tre
concetti spero ben chiari
iniziamo un percorso iniziamo a pensare
a cosa sa che approccio noi avremmo sul
nostro conoscente un nostro amico o
anche uno sconosciuto venisse da noi con
la richiesta di finanziarlo per una
propria idea imprenditoriale che
approccio avremmo questo è
il mio lavoro il mio lavoro di venture
capitalist e questo è il nostro il
nostro approccio
noi investiamo guardiamo presentazioni
guardiamo business plan sue idee il cui
successo è altamente improbabile è che
si basano su idee e servizi tecnologie
che non ager parte di casi oggi non
esistono
vi rendete conto che l'inversione di
quei paradigmi di cui parlavo prima è
alla base del nostro modo di ragionare e
soprattutto alla base delle nostre
scelte di investimento ma perché oggi è
fondamentale che tutti noi ogni giorno
iniziamo a invertire questi paradigmi
perché nel 2006 queste aziende non
esistevano e oggi sono parte integrante
della nostra quotidianità
non esiste
da facebook facebook ha cambiato il
mondo
pensate che oggi 2,4 miliardi di persone
almeno una volta al mese accedono a
facebook 2,4 miliardi cioè la metà delle
popolazioni che hanno delle persone che
hanno accesso a internet potentissimo e
facebook ha cambiato il mondo ha
cambiato il modo in cui i foriani
contenuti in cui conosciamo le persone
restiamo in contatto con le persone ha
cambiato il mondo dell'informazione ha
cambiato persino il linguaggio della
politica e instagram a io amo la
semplicità dell'innovazione potente di
instagram oggi anzi non oggi
ieri tutti noi guardavamo gli eventi
live dal vivo coi nostri occhi
invece oggi è tutto mediato dalla
videocamera del nostro smartphone e poi
condiviso a centinaia migliaia di
persone tramite instagram nelle altre
piattaforme social
e questo il risultato
chi ha capito che questo sarebbe stato
il risultato oggi è questo ovvero oggi e
in questo mercato cioè nel 2019 il
mercato dei social influencers solo su
instagram cuba 65 miliardi di dollari
capite l'importanza di invertire i
paradigmi e di velocizzare e 15 anni fa
noi eravamo tutti dritti schiena eretta
guardavamo la strada oggi sono tutti un
pochino ingobbiti a guardare il
cellulare chi mi scrive quando io ero
adolescente per far capire una ragazza
che c'era dell'interesse facevo gli
squilli e aspettavo
e uno squillo mi tornasse indietro
vent'anni fa mandavamo le cartoline e
l'innovazione ha cambiato i paradigmi
del concetto di proprietà oggi huber che
la più grande società
siamo così di taxi del mondo non ha la
proprietà delle proprie macchine non sa
come dipendenti
i driver arbia in b la più grande
società al mondo di hotellerie diciamo
così non ha la proprietà dei servizi e
dei beni che offrono alla proprietà del
proprio camera
e allora se tutto questo è successo nei
prossimi dieci anni cosa succederà nel
innanzitutto vi dico che ben prima del
2040 3 inizieremo a mangiare carne e
pesce fatti in laboratorio attraverso la
manipolazione genetica e la riproduzione
cellulare
già oggi ci sono aziende come file su
snes sismi bensì smiths e tante altre
che stanno facendo stanno portando nel
mondo questa innovazione è fantastico
potentissimo pensate la tecnologia
diventare cosa può fare per la
sostenibilità grazie alla tecnologia noi
non consumeremo più le risorse naturali
al ritmo con cui le stiamo consumando
oggi queste innovazioni tecnologiche
possono realmente salvare il mondo
la realtà virtuale
pensate che stiamo guardando questo
investimento a san francisco di
un'azienda che rende tattile crede la
sensazione tattile cioè voi parlate
whatsapp su whatsapp parlate al telefono
e a migliaia di chilometri di distanza
riuscite a toccare la mano del vostro
interlocutore attraverso la combinazione
software e hardware incredibile sono
ancora abbastanza indietro è nel farlo
ammetto ma questo sarà possibile
sicuramente 2043
e pensate le implicazioni per il mondo
della telemedicina ad esempio e veniamo
agli artifici all intelligence noi con
vivremo con le intelligenze artificiali
saranno dell'entità che saranno di
fianco a noi
e pensate i temi politici religiosi
etici sociali e giuridici
se non investiamo i paradigmi non saremo
mai pronti a rispondere
la provocazione più più bella che mi è
stata fatta sull'intelligenza
artificiale salario lavoro se il lavoro
verrà preso dall intelligenza
artificiale dei robot come verrà
ridistribuito il salario si andrà verso
un salario un reddito universale per
tutti e le macchine lavorare nel nostro
posto non lo so però ci rendiamo conto
di quanto la tecnologia e l'innovazione
impatterà io amo pensare che che le cose
oggi avvengano a a questa velocità non
mi spaventa anzi ogni giorno che passa
ci sono sempre nuove opportunità per
fare qualcosa
certo un po di malinconia per queste
cose c'è anche per
esterì tualità sicuramente per questi
prezzi però io amo pensare che nel mondo
negli ecosistemi che abbracciano
l'innovazione la sanno capire la sanno
anticipare la sanno finanziare ci sono
centinaia di imprenditori che generano
aziende incredibili investitori che
fanno investimenti incredibili 407 volte
l'investimento quel capitale poi viene
reimmesso nel sistema finanziano
imprenditori crea capitale umano perché
i dipendenti di queste aziende sono
capitale umano incredibile capitale
umano uguale mobilità sociale e quindi
teniamoci totalmente 2043 prima cosa
perché a insaputa di mia moglie fare una
grandissima festa per la fine del mio
mutuo
siete tutti invitati mangeremo carne
laboratorio pesce in laboratorio
intelligenze artificiali che serviranno
il il pasto siete tutti invitati
però nella strada che ci separa dal 2043
pensiamo che siamo noi
l'origine di qualsiasi cambiamento
ripeto siamo noi
l'origine di qualsiasi cambiamento e che
grazie al lavoro che faccio ho la
fortuna di incontrare centinaia di
imprenditori che continuamente me lo
ricordano
mi fanno pensare che sono le nostre
azioni individuali del presente che
possono costruire il futuro che vogliamo
grazie
[Applauso]